que
[musique]
Au gateball, il y a toujours des gagnants et des perdants.
Masukara
Si nous perdons, gagnons la prochaine fois.
[rire]
Si j’échoue, pourquoi ai-je échoué là-bas ?
J'essaierai de ne pas commettre cette erreur la prochaine fois.
J'ai le sentiment qu'on va le faire.
Quand j'ai perdu beaucoup
Parfois je n'arrive pas à dormir, c'est tellement mauvais
Quand tu le roules
[musique]
Et je le fais ici
Maintenant l'Union de la porte de Tokyo
âge moyen
J'ai 76,6 ans
Environ 90 % d’entre eux ont plus de 70 ans
Près de 90 % ont plus de 70 ans
je suis une personne de
Quand je faisais diverses choses comme des tournois au sommet.
Après tout, ces gens
Concernant la santé, notamment les mesures contre le coup de chaleur.
Je dois y réfléchir attentivement.
[musique]
[applaudissements]
Je prends généralement des précautions lorsque je joue à des jeux.
Après tout, c'est à l'ombre ou quelque chose du genre.
Après tout, salez pendant les pauses
Il y a des frais, donc je l'achète et j'ai de l'eau.
Veuillez apporter le vôtre, alors assurez-vous d'apporter le vôtre.
J'essaie de m'assurer que tu te reposes un peu.
[musique]
délicieuxfroid
[rire]
[applaudissements]